Hi Chad, Hi Ryan, was geht? Gruesse aus Luxemburg!
Ihr habt ja schon einige Alben veroeffentlicht,
da wollte ich wissen ob ihr irgendwelche Lieblingsalben oder Lieblingssongs habt
oder ob ihr irgendwelche Alben oder Songs habt wo ihr denkt:
"Nun ja, das ist das Schlechteste was wir jemals gemacht haben"
Und meine zweite Frage ist: Gibt es irgendwelche Staedte oder Laender,
in denen ihr lieber Konzerte spielt als in anderen.
Ich hoffe ihr beantwortet meine Fragen, Tschuess.
Danke fuer deine Frage und es ist gut zu wissen, dass wir Fans in Luxemburg haben
Ja, es gab Zeiten in denen wir Sachen aufgenommen haben, wo ich dachte:
"Das ist wirklich nicht so gut"
und um ehrlich und genau zu sein,
eigentlich war da ein Video. Als wir das Video fuer "Rockstar" gemacht haben,
und ich den ersten Rohschnitt sah, dachte ich,
dass es der groesste Muell war, den ich meinem ganzen Leben gesehen hatte.
Ich dachte: "Das ist schrecklich, ich kann nicht glauben,
dass wir wirklich fuer das bezahlt haben, das ist schrecklich".
Und dann kam der naechste Schnitt und der war nicht so schlecht
und dann der naechste und der naechste
und am Ende davon war es ziemlich gut.
Aber ich hatte keine Ahnung, dass es vom ersten Rohentwurf, welcher nur schrecklich war,
zum Video wurde, welches jeder auf seinen Musiksendern sehen kann.
Und zu den Staedten in denen wir lieber spielen als in anderen StŠdten
Es gibt keine Staedte in denen wir lieber spielen als in anderen,
es gibt Tage an denen wir lieber spielen als an anderen.
Weil wenn du Donnerstag, Freitag und Samstag spielst,
ist niemand besorgt am naechsten aufzustehen und zur Arbeit zu gehen
und niemand ist besorgt wegen dem Babysitter und den Kindern oder was sonst noch sein kann
oder wenn jemand am naechsten Tag Schule hat
Montag, Dienstag, Mittwoch, wenn wir das lange Set spielen, siehst du ein paar Leute:
"Ich muss morgen zur Arbeit, kommt schon Jungs, spielt meinen Lieblingssong"
So ist das Ganze dann.
Es kommt also nicht auf die Stadt oder das Land an,
es kann vom Tag abhaengig sein
Nun heisst das: Wenn ich ueberzeugend bin
und die Menge sich morgen bei der Arbeit oder in der Schule krankmeldet,
dann hab ich meinen Job richtig gemacht und es wird ein wundervoller Abend
Jetzt weisst dus! Ich hoffe ich konnte ein paar deiner Fragen beantworten.